[Music]
bismillah alhamdulillah Salam alaikum
that's the greeting of peace is the
greeting of all the messengers of God
including Moses he greeted his people
with the greeting of peace and Jesus
peace be upon him who we love dearly
he's one of the mightiest messengers of
God that's right
no Muslim is a Muslim unless he believes
in Jesus and he greeted his followers
with the greeting of peace and also did
the last and final messenger who came
after Jesus no more messengers to come
the problem Hamid peace be upon him what
about all these different religions how
do they come about and how do we prevent
ourselves from making a new religion
because what happened was with the
previous nations you'll see that people
started introducing things mixing
paganism different cultural practices
with the pure monotheism
and then you got all sorts of different
things you got three in one form one you
got all these things that the prophets
never caught they never taught but how
do we as Muslims once we have submitted
ourselves entirely to the one god
Muslims Jesus was a Muslim Moses was a
Muslim Abraham was a Muslim why because
they all submit a Muslim is one who
submits his or her self entirely to the
one God and we have the verbatim Word of
God and the authentic not Lullaby
stories authentic teachings from the
last and final messenger sent a man kind
of problem hunger peace be upon him we
have a code of conduct we have a
blueprint how do we follow that and
prevent ourselves from following our
lusts and desires and mixing things into
the religion that there's no sanction
for their justification it wasn't
legislated from the creator of the
heavens on earth and and pretty soon we
we end up making some other religion
just as the previous nations they went
away from the teachings of the prophets
and now you have all sorts of corruption
all you have all sorts of manmade
ideologies so it's very important that
this topic that we're going to cover
that you have an open heart and open
mind and you're sincerely listen because
we're going to be talking about
innovation
and Arabic is a word that we're going to
define and we're going to give some
examples so we can protect ourselves and
so we don't go astray we'll be right
back here on today's show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
as-salam-o-alaikum greetings of peace
greetings of peace how are you good good
Hum Dil allow thanks is to the one God
the create tour has given us the air
that we breathe he's given us everything
that we have and the ability to be here
to speak to communicate on something
that's very important
Joan can you help us cover this topic
yes we know it hamdulillah sort of a
cinema a lot of it now what'd you just
say you said something in Arabic so
people don't have to take an Arabic
class what you say mighty God before we
start so he can bless our meetings we're
gonna be talking as you heard me mention
in the opening because we see that
nowadays there's many religions there's
many ways people saying there's so many
ways all roads lead to Rome but the
Creator through our time has revealed
what he wanted us to do a blueprint so
we want to stick to that blueprint but
as you see many people have innovated
people have made up things miss mix
paganism with monotheism made a little
innovation here you know added this here
touch here some salt here now it's like
a buffet people you know just take it
from the religion what suits them and
adding what they said but the last and
final messenger peace be upon him he
said that everything that you invent in
the religion this can lead you to the
Hellfire we want to talk about this
because we want to avoid the Hellfire
can you talk to us about the serious of
inventing adding or taking away anything
from the religion of the Creator that
happens in earth Islam submission to the
one god hamdulillah hamdullah
i think it's very very important subject
and this is one of the fundamental
things that muslims need to discuss and
to understand and I'm glad to say Islam
so I think the main the most important
thing is to understand what
slam mean Islam means submission
submission but to do what submission to
a mighty God and His law or submission
to your desire and your logic if we can
understand the the name of our Deen this
will save us a lot of headache so
summation are you ready to submit so
don't make your desire or your logic to
be partnered beside Almighty Allah are
you willing to do this if you wanted to
do this is so simple because one plus
one equal to if Allah Almighty seen in
the Quran a glioma at Mottola comdey
nakumo at mom to awaken Amity or a
little accumulation a Medina today I had
completed the religion for you
so can you understand what this mean
completed something complete doesn't
need addition this is the problem when
we don't understand or we don't believe
so and both of them a serious problem
what'd you just call it is from the
Quran the verbatim word of God Almighty
God Allah is the people he said it's
completely say it's complete so if
something complete you could not add to
it is this true you could not so now if
not to believe the verse you don't
believe what God is saying or you don't
understand it which one if you believe
it so don't add if you don't understand
it now we explain to you that something
is complete you could not add to it so
if this cup is full with water okay
there is no air if this full with Eric
so it is something completely add to it
and I'm not perfect it so when you add
in something to the deed you saying that
the Dean is not complete or that Allah
doesn't know how to do the deed or it
doesn't suit me so Allah doesn't know
about was born to be in the 20 century
or or 21st century and all of this is
serious problem
also he accuses the Prophet peace be
upon him accusation because if this is
something good why is the Prophet didn't
tell us about it so basically talking
about addition which he rejected in the
Islam you could not add anything to the
deal follow don't
in vain this is about the moon why is
this so important cuz I myself like many
people out there we have come to the
conviction this certainty that this
Quran is from no other than the creator
of the heavens and earth okay
it's rational its lot it has all the
evidence than a human being it's not
blind faith our mind our logic brought
us to this conviction that this is and
cannot be from anyone other than the
Creator so now I want to submit to it I
want to do also with the last and final
messenger told us to do I don't want do
anything else
okay so why is this important so
important and we would see that the
Prophet peace be upon him he had
mentioned in so many different talks
warning the people about this why is
this so important for a Muslim to not
invent maybe he feels he has some good
idea maybe he feels like you know what
it's a little bit dry here we're in a
21st century maybe we can spice it up a
bit it is the wrong way of thinking of
course because it still we did not go to
the principal the principal is say one
plus one equal to can we agree about it
yes okay when you became Muslim you said
what a shadow and then Allah in in the
one Allah what a shallow and mohammed
rasoolallah okay so this is one plus one
equal to what this mean worship none
other than Allah how according the way
of the Prophet so are you ready to
submit that the only one legislate is
Allah and the way how to do it according
the blueprint of the Prophet Muhammad
it's simple but it's so simple but we
keep deviated from it now when you say
we deviate what do you mean you said
okay now one plus one is two but define
what is this when when in Arabic what is
this word that you mean the innovate
invent mean to add to come with
something new and to reduce in something
so reduces something do we see this
happening in history like with the far
you know the true teachings of Jesus now
that it's evolved and we see that you
know this Trinity and 1+1 3 is one is
this something I started as innovation
now it's something
major like setting up a partner to God
of course of course because he given
yourself Authority because the source of
legislation is Almighty God not me not
you not the government not anything not
the logic so when you allow anyone or
anything to add now he's sitting a
partner beside God but it start with a
little thing or something that you think
is nice but generation after generation
the original is not going to be there
and you will have something that you
think is a religion but it's not a
religion I see I see so the foundation
is not there now you hold it to
something you assume is that it's a
religion but this is not the teaching of
a mighty God this is not the message of
the Prophet peace be upon you so are you
saying now because we just want to learn
we want to learn and we want to humbly
submit and do what the crater wants us
to do because we want to get to paradise
and we believe that the craters are most
wise he knows best
so are you saying just to follow what
God said if I do God's thing this is
Islam do God's thing what God told us to
do do that and what the messenger said
it it's so simple
listen and obey don't invent it slam
means submission so it's not mean
freedoms that you invent Islam does not
mean invention it means submission can
we understand this title to call
submission Islam that's no invention and
this is the way of life of all the
prophets Islam they all practice no.8 so
he the one is here pure monotheism
exactly and to follow their leader the
messenger let's take a break and be
right back with more here on the Deen
show
there always be someone that'll be there
to say something negative but at the
same time there'll be someone there to
say something positive awesome
just hold on to the Rope of Allah
everything in this universe can rely I
need a last minute
the Quran says don't kill women don't
kill children don't feel old people
don't attack the civilians this is what
the Prophet Muhammad told us you know
that the Prophet SAW shall have never
ever stopped a war against anyone back
here on the Deen show and we're talking
about innovation now what's wrong with
someone might say look we're in the 21st
century do we need to be riding camels
do we need to you know if the Prophet
peace be upon him was here he might be
wearing a suit
you know as long as it's modest he might
be riding in a nice car but are you
saying that look we can't keep up with
modern technology we can't now use the
microphone we're using a microphone this
is something that's invented an
innovation what do you guys say about
that okay we're not talking about means
of life we're talking about how towards
you you have two areas one is a
religious area relationship between you
and Almighty God how to pray how to fast
how to make the crowd make Quran how to
do this and then they say have nothing
not even an inch to add other means to
carry how your daily life is okay so
allah subhanaw taala he made everything
subjective for our own use and for us to
invent and think and to make the means
better is good of course instead of gone
from here to Makkah to make Hajj would
take you six months on a camel or six
years now you can go by aeroplane the
next day you are there this is fine but
when you reach it to Mecca you could not
make them off from okay I'm not going to
right I'm going to go left or I'm not if
left I'm going to go right I'm not going
to start to answer for Marvel fairies
not by Tawaf gotcha okay okay that means
is okay instead of me talking five
people only can hear me I'm going to put
a loudspeaker now 50 people can hear me
but the message is still the same so
don't change that the law of God about
what he said but other things that it
can ease things and facilitate things
it's fine so we have to to to define
that we're talking about addition in the
religion in the religion not in the
early life acts of worship
exactly but riding a plane or even rides
the wind if we can no plane okay so
we're not talking about that we're
talking about matters of worship
anything that you that is legislating
that brings you closer to God so if God
legislated to pray five times a day you
can't now mandate it to pray seven or
eight this would be invention is the
Deen okay we talking about the D is a
religion adding something to the Quran
for there's 114 chapters is memorized by
millions you can't add or take from the
Quran 13 either the way how to pray too
fast all these things is already six
there it's sealed
he said complete it's completed what
about taking the Quran I'm putting it on
CD and giving it to somebody
is this something more this is a mean
that's a means I want you to do it to
distinguish between means and the
changing did he change the Quran itself
no now he makes the leads more visible
and more easier on people instead of
carrying a whole Quran like this in a
camel okay one time now you can carry it
between two fingers but it still a
hundred fourteen chapters okay she
didn't change anything in the Quran how
about the advance someone says look
before they just use the word Allah
Akbar Allahu Akbar okay
god is the most great God is more great
and I using a microphone so the
microphone is nice but Allah WA he did
not start as a Tennessee allahumma salli
ala muhammad no you still say allahu
akbar and he still say four times
because the prophet didn't like that
because the Prophet does is he's a
teacher he's the T exactly just like
Jesus at his time he was a teacher yet
to follow his teaching exact now our
teacher is the Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him we don't worship Muhammad no we
just we just wave for he as example and
leaders to show us how to do it okay so
if you want to learn jujitsu or you want
to learn
a boxing you follow Muhammad Ali you
want to learn basketball you follow
Jordan is that right you can if you cut
or maybe follow the trainer for you you
got a good jump shot maybe we follow you
but an act but but an ax a worship how
to get close to God you have to follow
the message of footsteps of the Prophet
whosoever your prophet in that time you
have to follow if you deviate one inch
you've gone astray and the last and
final measure that we follow now
exacting us how to get close to God
exactly the problematic job there's no
more messengers to come no no no no this
is the final and the last prophet if
anybody believe there is a prophet or a
messenger coming after the Prophet
Muhammad he's a disbeliever
what about largely Muhammad some people
say that he's a prophet no no no this is
deviation and this will lead to hellfire
so no property that he's a seal of the
prophets this is the last and the final
prophet and his book is the final
guidance anybody say anything different
from this or believe different he's a
disbeliever just real quick someone
might say that we as a people we never
had a messenger sent to us what do you
mean we are our people the Prophet
Muhammad sallallaahu l'm saying allah
had favoured me with five things
different from all the prophets one of
them were canon abuse of allah salla
Mubarak's willecombe near Gaza over to
Ellen a sermon every prophet came to his
local community but I been commissioned
to all mankind all mankind tell the
devil judge even african-americans
Chinese name it to anybody under the Sun
everyone on the Sun exact until the
devil even on Mars the moon if there are
people there is a marked it would be the
messenger for them directly so you can't
use that as excuse a result of this the
message of the Quran still in back or
reserved
has not been tempered like other books
because this is the final guidance so
Prophet Muhammad is the seal meaning its
stamp no more message you could not add
anything after a book my signature but
my seal this it you could not add okay
we're doing great we're going great we
want to learn we want to get to paradise
and we just want to follow us from it
just like an architect he has a
blueprint that certified advice stay
with the
blue-gray because the inspector Condon
you're following the blueprint now you
can add a third window for condos okay
so now talk to us talk to us this is
going good wareness as simple it's
something logical it's simple but some
people who insist are you say one plus
one is equal to tell them one orange
plus one orange so the same principles
apply same principle so we can not if
you're in Arabia and wherever you're at
you can you know weren't Muslims the
leaders of inventions as far as like
science and math and you know so let's
call this let's call it discovery ok
discovery because when you're talking
about invention innovation we talking
about the religious matter ok so I want
to just push this point so but Muslims
were the leaders invention but not in
matters of religion this is important oh
no no we don't invent anything in their
religion so these things were good in
Arabic how do you call it beta were
these good because like the invention of
soap and airplane and and cars but we
unknown it's through different subjects
you could not mixes its two things but
someone might say hold on hold on
because in my country we do it like this
and they say you know the Prophet peace
be upon him said that you know whoever
makes up a good bidder he'll have the
good of it there is nothing saying if
the Prophet never said whosoever do a
good bidder
he said man center-field is namely son
that that hasana if this is what you
mean Tommy express whatever revive is
sunnah a good son in al islam so it is
already been established is already in
the quran is already in hadith but
people slow down for that about it so he
come and revive it reminds the people
about it so the people start to act upon
it so he did not invent and then from me
is how to get closer to God like as
example somebody come this is a prophet
sallal a seller McVicker yes and the
Carranza was Corolla Cathedral alikum to
say who remember Allah a lot so you can
be successful so somebody will come and
say ok we're going to make vikram but
we're going to make it in
in United or what you call in
congregation we're going to hold hands
together we're going to stand and I'm
going to jump up and down and we're
going to have some music with it or
Channing you understand so encourage the
people do the Prophet peace be upon him
do what it's not
never did this this is not victory this
is nonsense okay this is not from what
amazing guy we want to get close to the
greatest God according the way of God
not according here this is a problem
here
you could know you have to go according
the blue brain there is a perfect brains
god yes or no yes yes he's sure okay
he'll so don't say yes he brains God and
the Quran say praise God and leave it
like this because they say son Luke
chimera in Timonium Sunday pray like you
saw me pray he went to make hi and say o
Hanuman Asuka come don't hide like me
so the Prophet in job is explanation
demonstration to show us L so don't come
with a different way now don't come down
the swing around yourself dancing son
like this what you call it Sufi dancing
and say we're making Vicar this is not
this not thick resist not Islam what are
you picking on some people now I work
this is this anything anything doesn't
matter you call it Sufi to free Mufi
call it what anybody do something
different from the way of the Prophet
SAW Allah send them and how does the
Sahaba understood it he's gonna strain
okay we're gonna take a break shape
right anymore we got some some questions
to ask you we will only want to get to
the bottom of this is very important
right back here on the Deen show when
the outside everything looks good you
see this hundred thousand dollar car you
see a lot of diamonds you see a lot of
females and they think that this is you
know this is a life this is this is like
no paradise right here or
which is my job to go into someone's
heart to change the heart your job is to
tell people what the truth is and the
alley of it is while we're sitting here
while I'm sitting here constantly paying
for the disease the cure was free back
here on the Dean show and we want to get
to the bottom of this because we want to
do things the right way not the wrong
way and we're learning we have the
knowledge the authentic information the
Quran the verbatim word of God and the
authentic sayings the Sunnah of the last
and final messenger and we can't do it
on our own don't we need we need
scholars people who finish you know from
the university people who sat with
people who are linked back to the
Prophet who have gathered this
information so what is it for me to just
pick up you know this information on my
own how you know how valued our scholars
in Islam people who are the physicians
who know this religion do we have to
turn to them because they're the ones
who are the inheritors of the prophets
exactly eggsy is the prophet sallallaahu
l'm he told us anime what I said to MBA
so that the scholars are the one who
inherit or the ears of their the
prophets what did they inherit the
religion but still we could not give
authority to the scholar to give us
something that is not bad up by Quran or
Sunnah and the understanding of the
Sahaba Islam commanded us to go to those
who specialized was LOL @ viki fez LOL
exactly in kuntum letter gotta go to the
scholars ask is the scholars if you
don't know so you are obligated to learn
but if you don't
the knowledge you go to those who have
the knowledge and ask them but in the
same time listen to this carefully
don't the giver is smarter the scholar
don't think the scholar any word coming
out of his mouth is revelation so he's
not infallible like some it comes of age
you know in in Catholicism they take the
priest as he's like the toad engine do
we take the same no the scholars is
infallible they don't love him who gives
them respect to be understand I learned
them from them but we did not give them
as much that is mean he's what you call
infallible infallible does that mean he
never make a mistake yeah okay now we
make him like he became another prophet
he did there is no scholar receiving the
revelation so as long as it's safe to
say as long as this scholar he's quoting
to you the book of the Creator Allah and
the the way of the price he's not making
it up according to this exam you follow
this of course is it okay to ask the
scholars say you know is this an insult
to ask the scholars say can you like
just because you want some more
certainty to to have him provide you
some of the evidence like if you go to a
doctor or someone and you just you're
about to have heart surgery and you want
to get two opinions maybe three and you
ask the the doctors using some fancy
words but you want him to elaborate and
just give you some some background some
evidence I guess what to me if this
person is a true scholar is the true
scholar he's never going to be
disappointed when you ask him because
you don't want to be a blind follower
you don't want to be taken for a ride
okay and it is his right to explain to
you from what he got it this is your
right to ask this but we have to learn
how to respect and how to ask us does
not mean because we want more and we
want to be sure that would be disrespect
now tell me
we have for the great Imams may God
bless their souls I mean now Abu Hanifa
loves his soul and imam malik
and shot other fellows but this is a man
for would they be saying the same thing
you're saying all right are you making
something new here
look Emily craft Malayalee yeah this mmm
Melek say that whosoever add anything to
this deen assuming that is good that is
not part of it
indeed he claimed the Prophet Muhammad
betrayed the message for Colonel sella
and this is my Manik he's one of the
great amount of course he's saying any
man any human being you can take from
his same or he can reject with exception
of one man and he pointed the grave of
the Prophet this is the only man that
you could not question in him other than
this you can take or reject doesn't
matter
big turban small terrible long beard
short bill no beer is it still a human
so same like the doctor he links it back
to his education he's learning it from
some kind of source yes so as long as
that doctor is is operating on and
proven facts it's good but now same
thing in the religion in this way of
life from the creator of the heavens and
earth if the scholar he's linking it
back to the verbatim word of God the
Quran and the authentic teachings of the
last the final method understanding was
a Sahaba and understanding now hold on
some moment cuz you you you know we're
must son
we're once who submitted to the will of
God someone might say you know I mean is
this this you know the people like
throwing names out at people and they
what the prophets they stood in
preparation and ones that receives the
religion but this thing you're teaching
now just something this will who be will
she be what you know there's some new
idea chin any idea of Salafi ISM or with
no names slams what do you call yourself
my name is Muhammad Radley and what I
mean what do you label yourself as I'm a
Muslim you're a Muslim Allah say well
otamatone the eleventh amendment by
ELISA are Muslims so we have no other
religion other name other than its
leader this is not some sect of Islam no
no no I'm not usually famous we want to
get to the bottom of this listen is the
freaking theory free speech understand
it you don't like you understand my show
you're not asleep you're not a big Sufi
Sheikh I'm not anything other than
comedy I'm Adi he or Budi or whatever
this sudhi
you said you're a Muslim yes is it and
we have to learn that what you know how
to learn the Islam the Book of Allah the
authentic Sunnah of Rasulullah saw Selim
how does the Sahaba understood it this
it those were the Companions of the
Prophet lived with him ate with him of
course okay so they don't need a
dictionary to know the Arabic words they
don't need that of Seir they don't need
say Harry yeah they took it directly and
the practice in front of the prophet and
the Prophet approves him yeah and say
and I come Basu Nettie was soon 18 holla
Pharisee dinner Medina man body follow
my son and the son of my guided Holly
for after me yeah and he says the best
people are my century so I'm not making
up something I'm saying Allah says the
Prophet say this all what I'm saying so
he told us to follow the Sahaba
understanding the collective opinion now
did this tradition continued on after
the Prophet and after his generation and
then 300 years it kept going with some
of the great scholars yes there's
nothing that just came up from a hundred
years ago two hundred three hundred
years no more problems that we don't the
study will don't clear and we think is
something coming you and we'll start to
label it or stay from him he says he
said and this is easy to throw a label
on people so you can stay away from the
truth yeah
we teach nothing except pure yeah mail
coming immediately understand from the
cow you don't have to add water you
don't have to add any chemicals yeah
pure yeah forgive me if any if I was a
little bit you know we just want to get
to the bottom of this and it's this is
more important in her I don't think you
can get to the bottom of it today yeah
they weren't you need to talk more about
it if that's why if you don't mind we
would like to do a continuation of part
Tuesdays so maybe we can give some
examples we can give some examples ok ok
and I thank you very much and forgive me
because this is a very this is our
salvation we want to go to paradise and
we want to do things God's Way not our
way thank you thank you so we could do a
part to each other
thank you God willing up two and three
and four yellow after four I mean for
you know thank you very much may God
Almighty to create a lot of reward you I
hope you're getting the benefit I surely
am
learn we're trying to be open-minded
humble hearted and we just want to do
things God's Way a laws way the crater's
way we don't want to follow our lusts
and desires because you know what we
could be wrong we can have a good
intention but that's not enough we need
the blueprint the blueprint the
blueprint is the Koran the verbatim Word
of God and the authentic teachings of
the last and final messenger and we got
to go to credible people scholars the
physicians of this way of life who
studied even more than doctors who
dedicated their whole knife life to
explain this way of life and it's
beautiful that we have scholars who come
on the Deen show people who've studied
with some of the great scholars who's
finished from Medina University Azhar
University who've who really have the
knowledge that we can benefit from and
we're gonna have to continue on and do a
part two to this so I hope that you join
us next week same time same channel so
we can continue on this very important
topic and we can all benefit together
God will inshallah until then peace be
unto you coming to the truth requires
two things it requires deep thinking
that you've already done but it requires
another step and that's courage if you
have the truth but you don't have
courage you won't stand up for the truth
and that's as good as standing up for
falsehood I would say this thing that
you're just told thing it's not in the
scripture and they would say a marginal
note added by a scribe yeah okay we know
that and I'd be thinking if you know
this is not the Bible why are you
preaching it as if it's gospel truth
bismillah alhamdulillah Salam alaikum
peace be with you I may be your host
you're watching the Deen show and we're
continue on this week talking about in
Arabic it's called bida it's very
important it's one of the fundamentals
of Islam we believe in testify that
there's no other God except the One God
and Muhammad is the last and final
messenger we established the prayer five
times a day we pay the zakat the poor do
we fast during the month of Ramadan and
we go on the Hajj if you're physically
and financially able once in your
lifetime and we don't add in this way of
life nor do we subtract and we're
talking about this we want to have the
best manners we want to be the most kind
to people the most generous but we want
to be make sure that we're doing it
God's Way not our way so we're going to
be talking more about this topic which
is very important this week on the Deen
show sit tight don't go nowhere
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
assalamu alaikum peace be with you
greetings of peace and you're doing
thank out humble ah yeah how you doing
I'm glad to be here
um we're glad you're here and God
willing that we can all benefit from
some of your knowledge and this is a
very important topic we want to worship
none but the Creator we don't want to
worship a man or woman but the creator
of man and woman and we have the best
example who is a mercy to the world the
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him if
you were living during the time of Moses
Abraham Jesus you have to follow their
teachings right exist you don't have to
pray to them or through them did you
know no no no you just worship the One
God
yes according to their way this is the
Sun this is what Islam means to
surrender and to submit to be obedient
sincerely to the one God and this is how
you get peace yes now tell us we and
people can go back to the Deen show.com
you have your own section there and they
can watch part one of this so we want to
continue on and let's kind of summarize
what we talked about okay about this
word innovation and religion can you go
ahead and summarize it briefly before we
give some examples of some of these
before anybody have misunderstandings we
learned from the last rasoolullah we
define in Buddha means to add something
to the religion not two means and ways
to carry the religion there is a
difference between the religion itself
and means to practice this ok so not to
be any misunderstanding you allow to
invent a car with four wheels two ears
one wheel you if you want to invent
alien flying carpet anything is fine
flying carpets cool it's cool a flying
carpet if we can invent that it's all
good it's fine that'd be really cool
yeah but you did not invent in the Dean
itself you don't add to the Dean what do
you mean Dean the religion that know the
religion the way that God Almighty
had the religious slated for you through
the Prophet Muhammad Sal Allahu Alem
understood by the Sahaba I want to add
something very important here is that
religion oval Islam is complete so there
is no need for anybody to add to it I
want to support this so we can come to
our subject today the the scene of the
prophet sallallaahu l'm man i mean i'm
annaliese ali imran ER for horrid we
could not be in building building
building okay but we send in the
Foundation's the whole single class what
I mean by this you have a good intention
but if you don't have the proper
knowledge now the whole building will
collapse
so a person who want to worship Allah
and want Allah to accept his good deed
he have to do it according the way of
the Prophet SAW Allah Allah not
according the culture not the way of his
school of thought not his logic so the
Prophet say whosoever act upon any thing
in the deal
which is not agreeable with what I
thought is going to be rejected by the
way I have a book called termites the
north's termites termites those are
insects that you know so you have the
word you have the building but some
things they're eaten up and destroyed so
acting an innovation not according the
way of the Prophet this was innovation
that mean you're doing worship but not
according the way of the Prophet this
will be like the termites eating up and
destroy what you did if Salah if its
first thing if it's has anything that
Allah legislate or the Prophet SAW Allah
send them you have to do it according
the blueprint the blueprint the
blueprint the same way as we said last
week you have an architecture because a
blueprint
you can't erect a building according to
after I once wrote once you have the
stamp of pool you got to do it according
blueprint this it inspector comes tears
it down exactly yeah the same thing that
expected here is the Prophet SAW Allah
sent him and he gives you the blueprint
his Sunnah
this makes sense so okay five pillars
you don't make seven pillars exist LOM
exam five daily prayers you don't make
two or seven it's five daily prayers
Roger
say look at the profit did it everything
have to be according the way of the
Prophet you could not make your own way
and then you had mentioned also
microphone writing about me if you want
me as fascism you know that's fine okay
yeah when you call the event in the
microphone all what you need a large
your voice for larger group to hear you
but you did not change the wording of
the event itself okay you did not start
with hi Alice Allah or hi Alan no you
say Allahu Akbar okay so the event is
still the event but you only use this
means to make a treat you to somebody
else that's fine I'm talking here incest
told you somebody all the way there in
India or China can see me can hear me
this is me making the Quran into as the
Prophet peace be upon him someone might
say look you compiled the Quran and made
it into a book okay is this a good
bidder
this again is me that means like he
takes the Quran from a book you put it
in a CD but this is the Quran itself
exchange then change the name work the
same words the same numbers of verses
everything I did not change that for I
see can you say this can you say that
anything that the last and final motion
of our Muhammad peace be upon he had the
ability to do and he didn't do it and
now you're doing it now you can't you
could not do it okay if the means
available there and their needs exist is
here and he did not do it you could not
do it I see well what about if someone
says looked one of the people that the
Prophet peace be upon him said that
follow his Sunnah also the rightly
guided companion okay and then he had
collaborated and put the taraweeh prayer
in a Jamaat in a common Roman yeah but
yes there is to support for this number
one Rama radhe lon is one of the falafel
Rashidi
what is it what does that mean one of
the main leaders of the Muslims main
Khalifa yeah okay the one who's in
charge of the Muslim Ummah the Muslim
community large
okay so the prophets of Allah sallam he
said that to follow his son his teaching
or his guidance because the prophets of
Allah Allah been informed and been
that those people are not going to
deviate from his way yeah so he said
follow my son and the son of my right
had guided her live this order from
though they're the ones that live with
him exactly and they already been check
up in many incidents and many cases that
these people would to be like this yeah
so this is number one number two this
not a beta because the prophets of Allah
seldom had pray taraweeh or km in lane
for two or three nights in congregation
yeah but the Prophet had stopped because
out of fear and mercy for his Ummah is
followers that Allah maybe will make it
obligatory in the Ummah
so he stopped but he had established
this in his life for three nights so now
since is a prophet die salah salem there
is no new revelation to make this prayer
obligatory so now armor or what he did
he brought it to the original that was
in the term of the Prophet Muhammad did
not do something new yeah he did not do
anything in you didn't do anything new
no real quick real quick before we go to
break just briefly cover we covered this
in last show but I think it's very
important where if someone says that the
Prophet peace be upon him said that
whoever introduces a good bid they don't
have a reward of it there is no good bit
that is the word in Arabic bida
renovation of Islam is Sunnah can husana
revive it there is it will buy refine
you forgot about it but you bring it
back zactly exactly the same this you
will get the reward of doing it and the
reward is also follow you know when we
come back and you give the context of
his disease no problem we'll be right
back with more here on the Deen show you
have to pray as if everything depends on
but you must work everything depends on
you that's my point you see the same and
I don't like that I don't like us
sitting here what are you waiting for
what are we waiting for right now what
are you waiting for all these people
that come to Islam what are you waiting
for what are we waiting for right now
when they're gonna come they're gonna
come along and bring these people lots
of fun I wanna put in our hand the
ability to do it now do your job
[Music]
back here on the Dean show and we want
to follow the blueprint we want to
follow what the creator of the heavens
and earth legislated and he revealed to
his last in front of mr. problem Ahamed
peace be upon him we don't want to
invent we just want to sincerely submit
to everything that the Creator wants us
to do now before we went to a break
there was one hadith authentic same from
last front of messenger can you give the
context of this hadith okay a few a few
of the Sahaba full of Sahaba okay
homeless needy they approached the
mosque the Prophet unbalanced Ella felt
bad when he saw the condition he invites
the people to give sadaqa charity one of
the Sahaba he went and he came with a
big baggage okay he barely can carry it
okay so when's the rest of the Sahaba
saw this they ran to their house ran to
their houses and this was in sentiment
or encouragement for them so everybody
went and came so charity zakah is
already in the Quran and already the
Prophet invited the people to do but
what the man did he set himself example
to be the fairest in the nation
so the rest get encouraged so he had
revived it sooner so the man did not
come with a new idea in the religion so
it's a misunderstanding for people to
say there is a better hasana or there is
nothing called better Hassanein in the
deal in the deed the Prophet saying
listen to the Prophet so in kalila more
deficit in Veda kukuli labayda $10
amapola dolla to phenom this is a
statement of the Prophet say every newly
thing anything in you added to the deal
is innovation every innovation every is
misguidance and every misguidance in
Hellfire but doesn't Islam someone say
look what about our manners our
etiquette shouldn't we be perfecting
this and we shouldn't be concentrated we
got so many divisions amongst the
Muslims and so much division came as a
result of Beta Beta is one of the main
causes that cause people to be divided
if all of us will come a bunker
Hadees the understanding of the Sahaba
would be United
but the problem because everybody
follows their last their opinions was
the school said was the chef said what
is my country do so better I is one of
the main sources at cause division among
the Muslims if you want United the
Muslim brings him back to the source to
the blueprint and still now for someone
to hear this
should we if someone approaches someone
should they do it in a polite way in a
nice way not a harsh way of course you
have to understand the time that you in
and how the people so far from the Dean
most of them in understanding they have
good intention but they don't have the
proper knowledge and this was a poor
unsane yeah although illegible Arabic a
bit Hickman one more ethical Hannah
invite them all to the way of your lord
with wisdom not how to admonish not
Harshman no no no we got to be kind with
the people's gentleness we agree about
it yeah but we could not understand kiss
- if we will say ok brother is OK all
the roads lead to Rome no is only one
way to Allah a dynasty rotten stocking
hidden a Sarah Thomas talking so smiling
and probably her hands and keep walking
and not saying anything about it this is
not fair what about someone says
priorities look people aren't even
praying people barely the person just
came to the mosque ok you know he don't
even he just comes on Juma and now
you're bombarding him with all this
stuff ok we did not this we say have the
right approach
hikmah more editor has a net so it's
time for salah teach him about salah if
it's time for fasting teach him i'm at
resting but don't teach him prayer
fasting the carriage is the fairest hour
because it's not time for hands you can
wait for six seven months yeah but teach
him now about what you want to do ok
Garin nicely kindly and it may be going
to remind him again and again i have no
problem with being kind and gentle the
prophets allah wa sallam taught us by
his methods this companion he came and
he related in the mosque
what's more than this and say leave him
alone nobody disturb him and after this
real nicely so invite the people to
listen according the sunnah now we want
to give some examples someone also
before we get into some of the
that people have send us and also that
we see a lot of times and it's confusion
it creates kind of a confusion immense
new Muslims and they're like why in this
mosque they do it this way you go over
here it's different so they ask these
questions and we want to clear this this
confusion so people can worship their
Lord in peace some of my sages before we
get to this debt you know I heard one
lecture speaking and he was talking
about this topic he said he was in in in
a Muslim country and then it said on the
advertisement it said say subhanAllah he
said look that's your bidder is this
something as big a did we go to that
extent that you can't even do that
what say subhanAllah it just said say
subhanAllah like it was driving and it
was encouraging people to say
subhanAllah
so the presenter said look that's your
bid ah why are you doing that so if
somebody reminded you about allah
subhanaw taala okay this is this is our
duty to each other but if we say in it
that this is the way it's supposed to be
that every two miles it have to be
Subhan Allah and then after this become
all over the country and everybody
thinks that this is part of the deal
this turned into innovation in the Dean
yeah you see but if somebody understand
telling him as example let me give you a
clear idea give me clarity as example
some people before they pray no I -
suddenly further Barbara Cartland are
the motorman better than a map and they
say a long thing what did you just say I
attend to make my prayer for the
according the school of thought of mmm
saw so behind this Allahu Akbar so
everything you want to do with these I
have to say that's the intention this is
the intention did the Prophet peace be
upon you is this something like this
this what we talking about no you're
inventing is it you made it standardized
you know it's adding the original
blueprint exactly and now the problem
became the others flourish all over -
found in front millions of Muslims in
donek like this and everybody before
this all but the Prophet say Allah
what's the proper way the problem all
the attention where the attention is in
the huts in your heart has nothing to do
is the tongue okay so you don't when you
go to your work in the morning do you
say I think
go to my work or you go if I get in the
car and watch it all makes sense it
makes sense so God knows what you want
to do and if it is going to mix a lot
this is not going to off you may cancel
out so what you saying who you saying -
so you have the intention in your heart
before you make we do you say bismillah
these you intention is the heart yeah
saying it is better saying saying the
intention with your intention is in what
you started with boss many I have it you
have it in the heart you have it in the
heart that's one example okay so moving
on what other examples now we see that
in some some us should you'll go there
and they'll have like after the prayer
and I've heard some new Muslims people
will come they say man this is so many
prayers all combined and it's it's so
many rituals after it like for instance
they'll come and do let's say a shower
prayer and then afterwards they'll have
a group vicar and then after that
they'll raise their hand and said in
Fatiha and then it goes on for half an
hour
tell us now this group thicker
afterwards and all these things that are
added and it now you go to pray Isha and
you want to spend like 10 minutes or 15
you're there for 9 min of this is sunnah
of the prophet salaallah same the
professor Lala Salama recommended for us
that we say subhanAllah 33 after Salah
hamdulillah allah akbar 33 ok but
there's a prophet do it is this what
about if i don't have time i have to
leave
can i say it while I'm driving as exam
can you of course why not
ok so the problem here when is
tenderized something and you make it
officially and became everybody new
Muslim or things that this is the way
but we're trying to encourage people to
pray the sooner afterwards
so everybody's doing it soon after it in
actuality the proper way to do the
Sunnah is in your house not even in the
mosque so the Prophet Allah Allah Allah
said don't turn your houses to be look
like a graveyard make the Sunnah in your
house he said that the problem today and
it's of course and he says that is more
rewarded to break the Sun that's the
optional prayer exactly oh that's a
makers the kids your kids will see you
in their emulate your house then they
think only the wife will mix Allah
because they want to see the father also
mix Allah I
so the more rewarded for the Sun is too
bright in the house more rewarded to
obligatory prayer to make it the
modelsim people get together after the
prayer and they're all saying let's say
coal wallah I had a lot o together like
different people raved about it so we
can make the house shake no no the shake
shake it meant shaking McDonald's there
this is [ __ ] it's a mask what about the
person came late he missed one raka he
want 2 mins Erica after they mm finished
he disturbing him and the person are
selling for business I harbor to raise
their voices he understand was the
remembrance of Allah never we know that
the Prophet made the Sahaba in Vicker
say subhanAllah subhanAllah subhanAllah
33 and after hamdulillah everybody hamdu
lillah what about if I taken my time
Isis you want to slow it down exactly I
want to think about it I want to feel it
and after this other person he's leading
me what no the Prophet lasers a happens
Allah but didn't lead him Vic so who
gave you the authority to lead the
people in say what was wrong with this
what's wrong that you are deviated from
the way of the Prophet I want to think
about it but now you finish
I didn't finish them yet if any 33 so al
hamdulillah so now I have to grab this
subhanAllah and go to handle Allah the
way of the after the prayer your
obligation is to pray what is it the
Isha for instance for mandatory units of
prayer this then afterwards we finish
and afterwards used to sit down and say
glory be to Yahoo don't say sit down say
you should remember Allah and do this
and that but he doesn't have to make it
in the mosque you could do it driving
you can Christ how are you walking
this is not individual any better for
you has no condemned ceramic to Lomonaco
Nakula
you disconnected you have nothing to do
with the email and they mem have nothing
to do is you in your own this if you
want to pray the option you could do it
as this is yours now see ok so don't
hold me under your authority understand
after a ceremony some people feel like
you know Timmy to stand up because
everybody now is you know doing these
rituals so you're better than people who
is not afraid from Allah or his
makes sense let's take a break we drive
back with more here on the D show say to
me why have you become a Muslim no I
give it very frivolous on should I say I
want to be on the side of the angels
[Music]
she's a number one rap artists in the
world he's sold over 60 million records
will be millions D million he was a
young guy where basically everything
that somebody you would think that life
is all about he had everything you could
imagine back here on the Dean show and
we want to stick to the blueprint the
verbatim Word of God the Koran and the
authentic teachings of the last and
final minister said the American Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him and Abu
Hanifa may Allah bless his soul and
these were a great amount there you want
to know all of them all of them are what
you say we have the follow of the
teachings of the problem or assuming
things about imam ahmed or mem Hanafy or
Imam Shafi
but we never read the books of those
people there is none of this mmm tells
you is okay to invent they never said
this you could not find anyone except to
tell you okay to do invent now tell us
an even assuming that one of them said
it assuming assuming resource assume is
that they said you could not because the
authority is with the prophets Allah
Allah say he's the only one receiver
villager
not just full of soul what about if my
heart my Sheikh he has some evidence for
it but now how do we know if evidence
about what like doing one of these
things but wait if if he how do we
verify if it's authentic hadith if it's
a fabricated now give me an example of
some how deep that people make a case
out of it but now it's come to be known
that it's fabricated or it's a weak
hadith do you have anything that some
people will do and let's say even how do
we verify the hadith itself excuse me
the Hadees itself can be authentic but
the understanding of the Hadees is
corrupted oh here's an example someone
said the angels they come where the
places of liquor are all of them and now
people say look the group there
we're doing it and we're gonna raise the
roof since we want to get out of these
and let's get the women in for everybody
together hold their hands and jump up
and do this that the other and they say
that the Angels come and they give this
hadith what you gotta say so the hadith
is authentic the demonstration of the
Hadees and the practice of the Hadees
the understanding of the Hadees is
corrupted I ask you a simple example
show me one single example that the
Prophet SAW Allah Salam leads the Sahaba
in congregation in Vicar jump up down
and raise their voices
one day they start say subhanAllah Allah
Akbar born in some is it a banana and
physical fair in the community but owner
or someone all our ever take it easy
don't don't make it harder in the self
you are not calling in one who's deaf or
blind here is you what you doing why you
shout him the one you callin in him he
can hear you he has no problem to hear
you he can hear you yeah and he's not
absent he's there yeah so the way the
hadith is authentic but the
administration or demonstration of the
hadith the action of the hadith is
totally deviation so if the Prophet
didn't do like that or his group Manion
you could not do it okay 40 days we gave
him 40 days when someone dies some
people now they commemorate the death of
someone and let's say they'll refrain
from God leaving the house for 40 days
and then they'll you're talking about
women or men or what women men some
cultures is different why is 40 why is
not 41 you see botanist stands there and
you make it a new test she making a new
legislation for the people the prophets
of Allah Salem says that is not suppose
for anybody mourning over somebody more
than three days that's what the Prophet
peace be a less it is a husband unless
it is a husband now you can have this
because the right that the husband have
over the wife even after his death now
she can go you understand for this
period of time
but does not mean that she don't eat you
don't a brain should only under talk to
people
no and the people will keep
commemorating and reviving this occasion
this is
Islamically a person died on what we
remember who make that for him but the
people nowadays he give a big gathering
and food and serving coffee and they
bringing somebody recite Quran again
this is a prophet do this when his wife
died or when his son died when his
daughter died why is the Prophet didn't
do this and then the Quran is collecting
dust and a and you don't read it during
the rest of the your occasions the Quran
became you understand in some Muslims
four occasions okay when somebody died
what is the Quran or somebody get
married as example okay so when they
give is that read Fatiha yeah what's the
relationship between reading frantic and
somebody getting that's a good example
and now you spoke earlier and somebody
died or you see all you remember shifts
on so say oh he died oh yeah let's read
the fatty so what's this this is another
what you say and involves this is if
after ever did this no companions never
did this abu hanifa they never did this
wrong name something different let them
bring call hair to bore Hannah come in
kuntum so the clean our religion is then
on evidence say bring your evidence if
you are truthful
go ahead ride in a plane go ahead and
ride in a car go ahead and recite the
Quran over the microphone this is good
but don't invent an acts of worship that
you feel are bringing you closer to
Allah you cannot do this don't they
invent - any new way to bring you closer
to Allah follow followers the Prophet
show you because this enough there's so
many things to cover there's so much oh
you come we come there are so many
examples but closing comments and
suggestions for how can someone who
might have been doing this for years and
years and now they have their Sheikh who
went to Hajj 20 times his grandfather
went to Hajj 50 times and this is how we
do it in my culture and my custom you
know and this is just embedded it's
ingrained in the people but now what
you're saying is making sense what
advice do you have for the sincere
worshipper of Allah who wants to get
close to Allah and he don't want his
deeds to get wasted talk to it get back
to the original get back to the
blueprint
come back again to the authentic sunnah
of rasulallah he Salalah salam always
search and look where there's a prophet
said how does the prophet do this it and
you have to understand your salvation is
in
the son of the Prophet SAW Allah Allah
the serious matter that is the day
majority means some people will come
come to drink from the fountain of the
Prophet SAW Allah Selim the angel will
drag him and takes him to the side say o
Allah this my people my followers say no
you don't know because they invented
after your death so if you want to be
separated from the Prophet not to drink
from the founder of the Prophet if you
want to be people from the people of
fire a terrible bata
you want salvation stay in the Sunnah
one of the greatest color said the
Sunnah is equal to the Ark of Noah he
also got in the ark they been saved so
so stay out of the ark they been
destroyed and drown so those people who
come above the Sun as a way of the
Prophet SAW Allah Selim those the people
who going to be saved those people who
acted on logic ideas philosophies
culture and innovation just the people
as the prophet sallallaahu LEM said
you're going to be leading them to hell
fire the seriousness of the matter a
person who committed sin drinking
boyfriend/girlfriend Aziz Haram they
eager to one day's you will repent
because he knows he doing something
wrong but a person who act in innovation
he think he's in the right track so how
he's going to repent so as as as a
result of this some of the scholars said
the person on Bataan is more worse than
a person who permitting major sins
because he's never going to repent
because he doesn't know better
this is serious serious very serious and
this is out of the love for the people
that now we want to educate and have
people really of course implement
according to the blueprint yes we love
our brothers and our sisters in Islam
and we ask them to come back to the
originality of this deal
Allah said the Prophet said the Sahaba
did you know and scholars who know this
Deen check with them of yours of course
thank you thank you come to me thank you
so much God Almighty before you they do
thank you thank you for tuning in to
another episode of the Dean show is that
a ABCs of a slap we just want to do what
God wants us to do we want to develop
ourselves to be the best human beings
possible God Almighty has revealed the
Quran which is the verbatim word of God
and the authentic teachings of the last
and final messenger prophet muhammad
peace be upon him and the scholars
they're the inheritors the inheritors of
the prophets so we want to sit with
people who know the verbatim Word of God
who know the example of the messenger
problem peace be upon him and we want to
learn want to soak in the knowledge we
don't want to add or delete we humbly
want to do God's will because God knows
best yes God knows best not us so we
also want to have the best manners and
etiquette and we want to be kind and
gentle with the people and this is one
of the most important things Islam and
we can't just take Islam like a buffet
what suits us we'll take it what doesn't
we leave it alone Islam is a complete
way of life we have to take everything
the manners the etiquettes the
submission and everything Islam has
solutions for all of your problems but
we got to get to know it take the time
and continue to come back here to the
Deen show and we hope that we can get to
see you next time inshallah God willing
so we can discuss some more important
topics until then peace be unto you